[Music]
hey everyone this is Simon and today I
talked to Christina tozi and we'll
gradara will is the owner of Eleven
Madison Park one of the best restaurants
in the world Christina Tosi is the
founder of milk bar and if you've never
tried her cereal milk ice cream you're
really missing out what a lot of people
don't know is that they're married and
this is the first time they've ever done
a podcast or an interview together
they're good friends I love them every
time I talk to them I walk away a little
wiser and this time was no exception we
spent our time talking about
relationships what relationships mean
how to cultivate relationships and how
relationships have changed during these
kovat times hope you get as much out of
it as I did and one of the things you'll
learn from this discussion is why this
is a bit of optimism
two of my favorite people in the world
how are you hi so if I this is the first
time you guys have ever done something
together right that's true I mean a
podcast together you've done many things
together the first time we've ever spent
time together alone in one direction and
I guess we did it together on the way
out but that's true that is true there's
the first thing we've done an interview
together or a podcast together or any
time together
because I don't even know who you both
are but not everybody knows that you're
a power couple or a couple no we're
doing this together in pursuit of our
relationship with you oh I love it it's
true which is the thing that I want to
talk to you about I love that
relationship relationships how did you
guys meet I'm just kidding
oh man so I okay I had a crush on her
for about two years before we met and we
were in the same industry and so we both
knew who each other were I probably knew
more who she was than she knew who I
I know who he was but you know girls in
like the food and beverage industry lot
less well back then at least there were
a lot less girls a lot more boys but she
she did this video that she put on eater
and it was her in Karlie Kloss
celebrating this cookie collaboration
they were they had done and me and a few
guys were watching and I was like oh my
god she's beautiful and they were like
yeah she is it turned out all of them
were talking about Carly class and I
couldn't stop thinking about Kristina
from that moment forward and every we're
in leotards which no that doesn't make
it pervy I was well by the way you're
the one that films it just means well it
just means you grew up in the eighties
yeah but so then every time someone that
I knew was meeting with her like through
whatever an event or this or that
every time I'd say hey find out if
Christina Tosi is single and every time
they'd come back and say no she's not
and then eventually one time someone did
they said yeah she's single and so we
were planning this charity event at
Eleven Madison Park a couple months
later and I made sure that she was asked
to be the pastry chef for that event so
good and because nothing makes more
sense than the pastry chef to the people
coming to make pastries at the best
restaurant in the world the most of a
displace yeah I'm just I see that very
obvious connection but Simon he also
like I show up his wing his wingman is
actually this like I think she's maybe
like 60 or 65 year old angel of a woman
that used to be Mick Jagger's personal
chef who's the kind of woman that like I
want to spend my time with in an event
like that she's super nurturing she's
super lovely she make connections but
also like we call when will doesn't
tractor beams you right we're like when
she's with you she's fully with you and
so it's not like hey what's up we're at
a party move on to the next one so this
one was like Paulie or my wingwoman
don't let her leave
now she was she was a guest at the
dinner I went out and I got her and I
said hey you need to come back to the
kitchen
when desserts are being plated and you
need to start talking to Christina and
don't let her leave until I'm able to
get her phone number because Christina's
the kind of person she'd come into the
dessert she's all business and leave and
so Paula kept her there until like 1:30
in the morning and gave me all the time
I needed and oh and then the other thing
and this is where it does maybe make me
sound a little creepy I said also I want
you to take pictures of the moment that
I start to like flirt with her because I
want to give her those pictures on our
one-year anniversary so my question my
question is is is there a shoe box
filled with pictures of all the girls
that you flirted like people say that to
me people like as soon as I met them I
knew we were gonna get married and I
think to myself I've had that thought on
a lot of first dates I know all joking
aside you understand how to form
relationships but you also and I think
that the thing that's magical about you
is is there's a difference between
transactional relationships and a real
relationship and you know how to
navigate both and I'm so impressed at
your ability you know because it's like
a little kid thing like you know will
you be my friend like that's not
supposed to work and yet you and I have
become dear friends and you got a wife
out of it you know just what just I
would understand where that skill set
comes from that's a dad thing when I was
a kid my dad gave me a paperweight
and on the paperweight was a quote what
would you attempt to do if you knew you
could not fail and his whole thing was
whatever it is you really want like ask
yourself that question answer it and
then just try to do that and so whether
it's aspirations for career or life or
friendship or marriage I think it's
having the confidence and conviction
such that you're willing to say what you
want out loud which a lot of people are
unable to do because you run the risk of
letting yourself or those around you
down if you say it out loud and then
fail to achieve it hmm but also how many
times have people said oh man that kind
of it would be really good friends but
then it ends there the difference
between like people that everyone has
good ideas it's the people that try to
accomplish them that go on to achieve
something and and I think there's no
difference between professional ambition
and personal ambition in that way right
Cristina what I love yours is um will as
a front of house guy you know he's a
he's a professional schmoozer and he
knows how to it's true I mean but
Cristina what I you know I've watched
your your baking Club and what I would I
you have a magnetic personality even
from afar and like people fall in love
with you that you don't know case in
point your man sitting next to you you
know like there are wonderful bakers
there are wonderful people in a kitchen
who who are unable to exude the passion
for their love of cooking or their love
of baking so out loud you know if
anything I mean I've not been in as many
kitchens as you have but I've been to
kitchens before and stress exudes for
sure yeah but but but passion doesn't is
rarely rarely exudes even at high levels
do you is there something that happened
as you were growing up that I don't even
know how to put it like no shit's given
like it just falls out of you you know
yeah one if you ever well one day you
will meet my mom and maybe a lot more
will make sense
she definitely raised my sister my older
sister and I or maybe it just rubbed off
on us but she definitely raised us with
a sense with a strong sense of self with
a sense of self that was that tried to
find the balance of like respectful but
also just unapologetically who you are I
think for like what what I might exude
that sticky to someone
I also like take things to like a level
I mean we were having with the three of
us were having dinner together the other
night and you asked me a question and I
get really excited about it or really
worked up I'll take it to a whole nother
level he'll be like okay okay okay I
love you so much be quiet but I think it
was probably being raised in an
environment where if you felt strongly
about something that that was encouraged
like as I simply put as that for the
good and the bad that it comes with and
then I think as I made my way in the
world not even necessarily in the
profession in the realm of food but
certainly in the realm of food that I
think I just learned quickly by like
taking other people's body language or
emotional temperatures through whatever
mannerisms tone of voice and so on to
say if you are willing to give part of
yours more than a part of yourself more
than where if you draw your line of what
you're willing to give in yourself and
you move that line forward and you give
more it gives people a little bit more
permission or to give more back or it
may be challenges in them what they're
able to give or it sticks and there's
most certainly an altruism to how I was
raised through action but then also
through how you hold yourself or what
gets you excited I was definitely raised
by a mom that I sort of say like she
made life happen and that wasn't in any
way other than the emotional like it's
Thursday like what are we gonna get into
today and she made the silly
she made moments silly moments or fun
moments or made holidays feel like
holidays and that's sort of just like
every occasion every moment is an
opportunity to do that and so I think
it's sort of like it's stuck to me and
shows itself in different ways one of
the things that I and and as you're
saying that I'm realizing because you
know when you're friends with someone
you don't think about the friendship you
know I don't think about why do I like
will and Christina you know you just I
just I'm really really excited every
time I get
talk to you're hanging out with you like
that's how it comes out so this
conversation is fascinating because I'm
sitting here thinking going why do I
like women and beyond the obvious you
know we get along we share values you
know you know the things that I think
all friendships have in common I think
you you individually but amplified as a
pair do something for others that
everybody on the planet wants which is
to feel safe being themselves and you
know I can I can say things I can do
things Cristina you get permission for
people to be overly excited about
something that people aren't necessarily
excited about like adding peanut butter
to a cookie you know it's exciting and
I'm just realizing when I'm with you
guys I'm immensely relaxed from the
minute I say hello and and then there's
a residual when I say goodbye I feel
very very relaxed and I have I mean I
hate the word permission but an
environment is set to be completely
myself works on all and it's always and
it's always with a laugh you know aim is
true in return to be clear and whenever
any of us says things that you know
we've all done this we've done this with
each other where you catch yourself
saying something like oh probably should
have said that out loud
usually it's met with a laugh you know
yes and either of you ever unfriended
somebody in real life not because they
did anything bad or wrong but you just
realized that the level of energy that
like you know unfriending is a thing
online but should it be a thing offline
and I'm thinking back when I learned my
why when I go back and this new journey
began for me and the big thing about my
wife was less about my career and more
about finding what I call a quiet calm
sort of like a quiet confidence rather a
quiet confidence in myself where I felt
totally I found a new peace and myself
that I didn't have to tell anybody about
I was just okay with being me you know
that was the big thing that came out of
my why and I remember I remember it
didn't it wasn't like as I sat down and
did it I just remember taking note and
realizing that I had friends that I was
the only one investing in the friendship
that if I never called them I doubt we
would ever have plans you know that I
would always be the initiator and
I might have enjoyed my time with them
like I had fun you know I had fun when I
was with them but did I have a deep
trust that I feel safe to be my complete
self around them probably not and that
that you shouldn't in an early
friendship but you hope that friendships
grow and progress like anything grows
and progresses and you can see if a
friendship is going that direction and
I'd been friends with these people for
years and I would call them entry level
friendships right they were like
beginning friendships even though they
were years old and so I started ask
myself questions like I have a finite
amount of time on this planet and I have
professional ambitions I have I have
service ambitions I have personal
ambitions all of which are about growing
and if I spend time with somebody that I
literally am stagnant around even if I'm
having fun should I have fewer of those
friends because I have other friends
that I am I can laugh but I can also
have deep conversations I can feel set
like myself and when I leave any kind of
interaction with them I feel slightly
better wiser than I was before I went in
and so I sent these really polite emails
to these friends I should try and dig
them up so these really polite emails
basically explaining how I really like
them I enjoy them but I recognize that I
find that I'm the only one investing
energy in this and I realized that it's
it's too much it's too much and I'm
gonna stop being the initiator and if
they email me or call me I will
absolutely take the call and would love
to see them but politely putting it
balls in your court like if you want
this friendship I'm here and neither of
them neither of them wrote back oh my
gosh no it was a good thing
friendship is such a weird thing because
it requires the same amount of pursuit
and investment in many ways as a
marriage not in all ways but like like a
breakup with a friend yeah is it pretty
like white why not like we you know but
but the thing that was important to me
was it wasn't mean-spirited my emails
were not angry they were not accusatory
they would simply matter of fact and but
it was a recognition in me that I I I am
okay with a few friends that
just fun that there's really no depth
there but I can't have that be too many
yeah you know and it's really I think in
any relationship there's accountability
on both sides yes and I think I had to
learn the lesson I've learned the lesson
and continue to learn ISM I'm still very
imperfect in this pursuit that you you
know we get busy with things but we have
to be accountable like I'm so sorry I
haven't reached out and I think it's
correct for friends to call and complain
when you've sacrificed and shut down a
friend of mine did it to me recently she
called me and basically scolded me for
having let the friendship down and she
was a hundred percent right
I offered no excuses because there's no
excuse there's never you know we
everybody says I'm really sorry I'm busy
we all have time to send the text to say
yeah I'm thinking about you and that's
all is required and and I all I had to
do was take accountability and then
prove myself in the weeks later that I
care about her immensely that didn't
mean falling but the just means going
back to the way it was where I just
checked in every now and then and told
her I was thinking about her for me the
easiest way to think about it is like is
energy based which i think is what
you're saying and what you're sharing in
a different way I think about it as what
I need what I want to give when I go
into a relationship a friendship is
energy obviously I'm gonna show up with
energy or it's obvious to me that that's
what I'm gonna show up I'm gonna show up
excited I'm gonna show up I want to give
more in a friendship than what's
expected and so on and the easiest way
for me over the past few years to think
about friendships is does this
friendship give me energy like it's not
about anything else
I don't need anything else other than
knowing that it's not gonna take energy
from me like is it that neutral or net
positive from an energy standpoint and I
think that's sort of the like when we
spend time together
it's fun and it's energizing whether we
talked about something heavy and deep or
challenging or light and silly and goofy
but at the end of it it's like you have
the energy going in an anticipation of
time together and you have the energy on
the way out you're not let down
emotionally yeah it doesn't feel like
someone like took from you from an enter
a standpoint and that for me is like the
easiest way to think about it
do I feel reenergize do I feel refueled
by time that's nice this person and I
don't think I don't think I don't think
the three of us have ever hung out ever
without one of us sending a text after
we're done saying I had so much fun like
it's not likely to your point about
energy Christina like it it goes with
you like when you say goodbye it's
actually not goodbye like you're still
it's the way I define ya I'll put it on
I'll use a metaphor that both of you can
relate to it's the way I define a great
meal like I love to joke about like you
know I live on the Upper West Side in
New York City and there's no great
restaurants on the Upper West Side
there's good restaurants like how was
your dinner was fine it was fine it was
good it's fine a great restaurant a
great meal is a meal that you're still
talking about after you've left the
restaurant yes like can you believe that
chicken you know I've never had lasagna
like that and then the next morning you
call your friend that you had dinner
with you like aa drink about like
lasagna you know but the point is is you
keep talking about the meal that's a
great meal it's not a good meal that's a
great meal I think I think and the same
with for the energizing thing and I
think also we're both in spite of the
fact that she's a chef she's in the
hospitality business and she embodies
that sense of hospitality and generosity
and nurturing as well as any dining room
person I've met I think when you are
that kind of person and you decide that
someone's important to you it's the
equivalent of like if we all like start
every day with a glass full to the brim
of water you're pouring your water into
the other person's glass and the best
friendships are where you each show up
with a full glass of water and you're
pouring your water into each other's
glass you don't I mean like it can't be
a relationship where you're always
filling the other person's glass and
they're never turning around and filling
yours
that's it makes me it makes me think of
two things which is relationship should
be equitable not equal yes an equal
relationship is I cook you cook I clean
you clean I take out the garbage you
take out the garbage that's an equal
relationship an equitable relationship
is I'll cook you do the dishes you
you put the plates away you enter the
dishwasher I'll take the garbage out
yes that's an equitable relationship
we're not doing the same things but
everybody feels whole and everybody
feels they're making their contribution
and the thing that you've been asked to
do might actually be really easy for you
and the thing that you're not doing it
might be really hard for you but that
doesn't matter
it's that both parties feel that the
relationship is balanced so it's
equitable but not equal and I think a
lot a lot of I've definitely made that
mistake and I think it goes with with
time and expectation as well so like
nobody walks around with a notebook in
their back pocket keeping track of all
the things I've done for you and you've
done for me and we don't sit down at the
end of the week like I did seven things
for you and you've done no things for me
you know yes for me the good
relationship is not so much the stuff
that is done and this goes back to the
the reason to unfriend is I may do a
thousand things for you I may be poor
filling your glass every day I might be
even the one initiating the plans all
the time this is actually really helpful
this is and it's this is I thought I
didn't have before which is I would
actually be okay making the plans and
being the initiator all the time if I
have the absolute confidence that the
one time I need you you will 100% do
even though the book is the book is
empty of stuff you've done of initiative
initiatives you've taken but I have deep
deep confidence that the one time I need
you the answer will be yes and you'll be
there no matter what yeah and then I'm
happy to be the initiator people do but
it like when you look at like marriages
that are breaking down
it generally coincides with the moment
that people do start to keep a list of
what the other person's done and you've
done it's almost like in any business
deal you do a contract and then you put
it in the drawer and you hope to never
have to look at it again right right the
moment you start like tallying like
who's done what for who is the moment
that you know you're already in trouble
yeah and and also I think to your point
like I need you I feel like the greatest
relationships are the ones where you
talk about equity yeah she's gonna have
off days and I'll be there when she has
an off day and I feel totally
comfortable
having an off-day myself and I think
that's true and friendship as well like
did I ever tell you did I tell you my
definition of my favorite definition of
love what love is giving someone the
power to destroy you and trusting they
won't use it huh oh I love that isn't
that mad I don't know who said it I've
tried to find out who said it I've
looked it up I can't find it but I but
I'm hoping but for me my love doesn't
have to be romantic love can be
friendship love and for me it's the same
you know I have friends who know things
about me my insecurities my fears you
know that even in the heat of anger they
could say one of these things that would
go through my heart and even in the heat
of ain't angry even when they absolutely
hate my guts in that moment they'll
never ever ever use that as ammunition
it's amazing so the question is is what
is that skillset to invest in and be a
good friend and have good friendships
back that's missing that we're not
teaching to people I mean you got stuff
from your dad will and Christine you got
stuff stuff from your mom and as you
were saying that I was thinking oh my
god my career like the two of you has
largely been formed by a lesson I
learned from my parents as well from I
remember going to work with my dad when
I was a little kid he was an executive
at a giftware company and he was as four
equally exactly as nice and friendly to
the person working in the studio as he
was to his to the other executives and I
just would watch it happen and I I
learned not it was never conscious it
was just a way I acted and I remember in
my own career I worked at an ad agency
and I remember like whenever we had
extra food after a I would always take
it down to the mailroom and share it
with the guys in the mailroom because I
knew that they weren't upstairs and they
didn't so like it was just the what
you'd is just what we did and years and
years later I was giving a talk
somewhere and one of the people came up
to me who was an executive and she came
up and said I knew your dad like 15
years ago whatever when I was a junior
junior junior person at this company
that he was an executive and I always
remember your dad because he was always
nice to everyone and to hear that was
choked me up you know to hear that 15
years later that that that it affects
somebody that much that they would
remember
like and I don't think we realize like
us saying hi to someone which we will
forget about and means nothing to us
like how powerful it is to see other
people and what we've all learned from
our parents is this idea of seeing
ourselves and seeing others and that's
the skill I think that's missing I'm
feeling seen and of course and feeling
seen you know I love all of that I yeah
and I think by the way I love that we're
talking about relationship right now
because what what a crazy time were in
full of so much challenge and difficulty
economic challenges for so many people
health death like so many so much
darkness right but in in it there are
silver linings and one of the things I
found like I think everyone is spending
less money buying less stuff doing less
things and there's a couple ways I would
articulate it one is like I think life
was full of so many highs whether it's
like going to work winning awards
running around going to dinners that
like the normal moment started to feel
like lows mm-hmm and so there's been
like a restoration in my life of beauty
to normal moments but along with that I
felt in me a restoration of appreciation
like this idea that I appreciate things
more now than I did before
hmm another friend of ours as a pastor
and he shared with us this prayer that
an older woman in the church shared with
him which is my prayer is that all the
things were being forced to do now that
we choose to do those same things when
this is over yeah and so like as it
pertains to relationship and as it
pertains to appreciation and pursuit and
all of these things might my hope is
that the things I find myself like just
forced to do that on the other side I
choose to do them because if if not what
a waste this whole crisis will have
ended up being in my life yeah I would
do just a loss of life and no and no
silver lining exactly realize what you
said I want to underscore it because I
think it's
it really touches a nerve that things
that were normal were lows because our
life our lives were so filled with
dopamine and adrenaline and the pursuit
of both in all its forms that anything
that didn't provide dopamine or
adrenaline was was a physical low yeah
and things like oxytocin and serotonin
which are the love chemicals you know
that take longer they're not quick hit
things they build over time yeah that
investing in friendship as opposed to
gambling with friendship because you
invest in things that take time to
gestate you invest in education you know
you invest in future as opposed to
gambling that we that we get we gambled
with our friendships we took bets on
friendships and oh and I can't we're now
we're in we're learning to reap to
reinvest in friendships and by the way
it's a long term it's a long term
investments a long term payback but it's
super stable but III really how do we
make sure that when the dopamine and
adrenaline come back that that that the
normal continue to be highs rather than
lows
I fear that yes yeah and I don't know
that there's any way to ensure it yeah
we are we are in the business of like
professionally we're in the business of
saying yes of always finding a yes yeah
it's part of my entire athos around
hospitality Christina will you add more
sugar yes in the dining room of someone
once X and we don't have that it's not
no it's yes we can do this right and
that's a dangerous thing in life if you
say yes to too many people you don't
have the ability to say yes to yourself
yeah and so she was saying that I was
like well maybe the right thing to say
is hey during this quarantine I found
that the best way for me to continue
being able to serve others is to first
pause and serve myself and that means
saying yes to less I'm so sorry that
that means I can't show up for you but I
hope you understand yeah
instead of saying yes to the dress say
yes to the list yeah and by the way it
has the added benefit of being the truth
which is a lovely thing
well III I've learned this lesson the
hard way and continue to learn it I'm
it's a it's it's one of the things it's
one of those annoying lessons that I
have to overcome because I try and say
yes to everybody because I want to make
good I want to make right and I what I
end up doing is putting myself so thinly
that I actually end up letting people
down you know and what I've learned is
that actually just saying somebody just
saying no to somebody they would rather
have a no than then a half-hearted yes
yeah well we have a question for you
okay no we're not okay my dad we've
talked about my dad already told you
what yeah put another one of his quotes
is the secret to happiness as always
having something to look forward to
yeah and that's a big part of our lives
and I think right now a lot of people
are spending a ton of time focusing on
all the things that they miss yeah and
in our home we've been thinking just a
ton about rear tick you lating that and
just it's amazing how when you switch
out a few words it can really alter your
perspective and so rather than talking
about what we miss we've been talking
about the things that we can't wait to
do again yeah yeah okay and so our
question is that we would like three
very specific don't like high level me
specific specificity we look like very
three very specific things that you are
so excited to do that you simply cannot
wait to do again I I'm really excited
like I'm very cannot wait to just go and
see friends again that doesn't mean go
out it's mean it can be out it can be in
but just to spend time with friends in
person you know I I'm spending more time
with people like this but I want to sit
I want to sit across with them I want it
I want to raise my glass and actually
clink their glass rather than clink the
lamont the monitor you know I really am
looking forward to to just seeing seeing
the people I love again you know so much
a couple things that I'm really looking
forward to are things that I've learned
during kovat so they're not necessarily
going back to but continuing I have
absolutely fallen in love with family
dinner it's something that I did when I
was a kid when we
kids we had family dinner every night
four nights a week and Friday and
Saturday my parents went out you know
home cooked dinner and my family we're
we cook dinner and we take turns and we
cook together and we clean up together
or someone will cook and the rest of us
will clean up and I am so enjoying that
ritual that I want to maintain that at
least once a week no matter how busy I
am I want to have a family dinner and it
could be with friends you know but I I'm
really looking forward to maintaining I
love that family dinner and another
thing I'm really looking forward to I'm
I'm looking forward to I think there's a
lot of lessons that we've that that we
humanity are learning and I'm looking
forward to people being more patient
with each other you know it's one of the
things I noticed the other day you know
there's a great article about how the
sale of pajamas has skyrocketed like
people have your good morning pajamas
your daytime pajamas or nighttime
pajamas and like my mother my mother
I've never seen my mother with gray hair
in my whole life she's probably been
great since her mid 30s but she's
decided to stop dyeing her hair because
mainly cuz she can't be bothered and I
haven't had a haircut in weeks and I'll
show up on like like important things
with a frickin t-shirt on Anna and I
look like a q-tip and it's amazing how
little I care right now you know and I'm
not being am not being subversive I'm
not being like well there you have to
accept me however I am I'm really just
fine if they think I look ridiculous and
it made me realize just how how much of
what we did on a daily basis was
actually not for us it was for the
consumption of other people no one is
wearing jeans right now the sale of
jeans has plummeted but the sale of like
leggings and sweatpants of a jobless has
skyrocketed you you can't get them and
and so I I really hope that everybody
just like takes it down a notch I'm
looking forward to all of us showing up
to work not in sweatpants and baseball
caps you know but just down a notch that
we're all a little more comfortable with
people being a little more who they are
and how they want to be and how they
want to show up rather than how we
expect them to show up hmm I'm hoping
that huh and that goes with ourselves to
write to your pen that goes with
ourselves to right here
so yeah right Christina calls that
comfortably human yeah yeah well well
give me why don't you give our parting
thought our parting thought I don't know
I'm like when when we were talking about
how do we ensure that we don't go back
to where we were before
mmm like I don't want to go back to
normal no and I said well we can't
insure it and that is the truth you
can't insure anything and then my mind
started drifting and I wasn't fully
present in our collective conversation
for a moment because I was thinking well
I also can't ensure that you and I will
stay marry and I can't ensure that you
and I will remain friends the only thing
I can do is pursue you and to pursue you
and I guess the best thing to do to
ensure that things don't go back to what
they were is to as individuals all of us
separately and collectively to
articulate as best we can what it is
that we're so valuing in this moment and
then pursue it and then surround
ourselves with friends and relationships
who will help us pursue those things
together thank you
here's what I've learned over the course
of this time with you and I always leave
wiser whenever I have learned that we
have spent so much time investing energy
and time in work and ambition and rank
and accumulation that because we only
have a finite amount of all of these
things that we fail to invest the time
and energy in relationships and whether
we like to believe it or not
relationships need a lot of investment
for them to for them to grow and for
them to thrive and what I have learned
is the importance of spending time and
energy on any on all my relationships my
professional relationships my personal
relationships my family relationships
because if I don't invest in them they
go away I love them I love you guys so
much they love you I just like I'm I'm
sure I'll be texting you afterwards and
thank you thank you thank you for doing
this thank you for coming together
I love your relationship I love how in
love you are you guys are always you
know nudging each other and hugging each
other whenever whenever you're together
I know and I for one feel very inspired
to continue to invest in this friendship
as do we yes I hope you enjoyed this bit
of optimism if you'd like more please
subscribe wherever you like to listen to
podcasts I hope you'll join me next time
until then take care of yourself and
take care of each other i'm simon Sinek
[Music]